you might have seen this problem on
social media with the title most people
think they know the answer to this
problem but they don't what is the
square root of negative four multiplied
by the square root of negative nine
let's work it out carefully since we
have square roots of negative numbers
you can't use your normal square root
properties
so if x is a non-negative number
Negative X will be a negative number so
the square root of negative X is equal
to I times root X where I squared is
equal to negative 1. so in this case the
square root of negative 4 is equal to I
times root 4 and the square root of
negative 9 is equal to I times root nine
now we simplify like we normally would
this is equal to 2i multiplied by 3i
that's equal to 6i squared which is
equal to 6 times negative 1 which is
equal to negative six and that is the
answer root negative four multiplied by
root negative 9 is equal to negative six
we have a negative answer